[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض ونبداها كالمعتاد بالعناوين
تلحق ان شاء الله
تفاهمات اكبر وزير الداخليه اليمنيه يكشف
عن تفاهمات سلام قادمه ويؤكد ان دعم
السعوديه والتحالف وراء التحرير الاسرى
الدفاع البريطانيه تكشف عن انسحاب اوكراني
من باخموت وسط قصف روسي بالمدفعيه الثقيله
الامير محمد بن سلمان يطلق واربع مناطق
اقتصاديه خاصه السعوديه قبله الصناعات
اللوجستيه والتقنيه
في الرابعه ايضا
اكثر من 22 مليون معتمر وزائر للمسجد
الحرام خلال شهر رمضان حتى الان وسط خدمات
متكامله
ارشادات واسعه بمسلسل سفر برلك توثيق لقصه
تهجير اهالي المدينه على يد العثمانيين
نبدا من اليمن حيث تتواصل عمليه تبادل
الاسرى بين الحكومه الشرعيه والحوثيين وفي
اول تعليق رسمي من الحكومه اليمنيه قال
وزير داخليه اليمن اللواء الركن ابراهيم
حيدان العربيه ان تبادل الاسرى خطوه مهمه
لاعاده السلام في البلاد وزير الداخليه
اليمنيه اضافه للعربيه بان التفاهمات
تفاهمات اكبر قادمه تخص عمليه السلام بعد
تبادل الاسرى المسؤول اليمني كذا ان عمليه
تبادل الاسرى مستمره لتشمل الجميع بعد
العيد
ان تكون هذه الخطوه الخطوه التبادل اسرار
المرحله الثانيه يعتبر من اكبر خطوات
تبادل الاسرع بادره
حسينيه مبادره خير تكلل المرحله التي قام
بها الاخوه الاشقاء بقياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
باعاده السلام الى اليمن واعاده الوئام
بين اليمنيين فهذه الخطوه تمثل مرحله مهمه
من مراحل اعاده السلام في اليمن وربوعه
كاملا
بالتاكيد بالطبع انه هذه الخطوه ستلحقه
خطوات اخر اخرى
بعد العيد ان شاء الله اللي هي تبادل الكل
مقابل الكل يعني وهذه اولى خطوات السلام
تلحقها ان شاء الله
تفاهمات اكبر حول اعاده السلام وتوحيد شم
اليمين بشكل عام في ربوع الوطن وقبل ذلك
وصل الطائره الصليب الاحمر التي تحمل على
متنها اسرى الشرعي لدى الحوثيين الى مطار
عدن وهي تقل 35 اسيرا من اصل 72 بينهم
اللواء ناصر منصور هادي شقيق الرئيس
اليمني السابق وزير الدفاع اليمني الاسبق
اللواء الركن محمد الصبيحي وبشكل متزامن
وصلت اول طائره نقل اسرى حوثيين الى
العاصمه صنعاء قادمه من عدن
هذا واكد الصليب الاحمر للعربيه ان عمليه
تبادل الاسرى اليوم ستضم 249 اسيرا بين
الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثين المتحدث باسم
الصليب الاحمر كذا في مقابله مع العربيه
ان عمليات التبادل الاسرى ستشمل خمسه عشره
رحله خلال اربعه ايام وستصل الرحلات الى
سته مطارات
مطار في الصباح الباكر
قامت فرق اللجنه مقابلتها الاشخاص والتاكد
من انهم قادرون صحيا وجسمانيا على الصعود
على الطائره والسفر الى صنعاء حتى هذه
الاثناء
طائره من مطار عدن الدولي الى صنعاء وايضا
هبطت طائره اخرى في مطار عدن دولي قبل
دقائق قليله سيتم خلال هذا اليوم التبادل
او
المئه وتسعه واربعين محتجزه السابق بين
اطراف النزاع المسلح ونحن لا نتحدث بين
صنعاء وعدم
في ردود الفعل رحب مجلس التعاون الخليجي
ببدء عمليه تبادل الاسرى بين الحكومه
اليمنيه والحوثيين وقال امين عام بمجلس
التعاون جاسم البديوي ان تبادل الاسرى
يعطي الزخم لجهود وضع حد للازمه في اليمن
كما شاهد مجلس التعاون الخليجي ببساطه
الوفدين السعودي والعماني في محادثات
الصنعاء مع الحوثين
المبعوث الاممي الخاص الى اليمن هانس
جراند فيرج رحب ببدع عمليه تبادل الاسرى
بين الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين وحتى
المبعوث الخاص جراند بيرج جميع الاطرافه
على الافراج الفوري وغير المشروط عن جميع
الافراد المحتجزين التعسفيا كما حثهم على
الالتزام بالمعايير القانونيه الدوليه
فيما يتعلق بالاحتجاز والمحاكمات العادله
من القاهره ينضم الينا نبيل عبد الحفيظ
وكيل وزاره الشؤون القانونيه وحقوق
الانسان اليمنيه سيد نبيل اهلا وسهلا بك
معي بهذه النشره اولا اريد
ان اقف معكم على المعلومات المتوفره لديكم
حول هذه العمليه هذه العمليه هي الثانيه
بعد عمليه
2020 الان ماذا عن القوائم على اي قاعده
يتم العمل فيها
الى اي مدى يمكن بالفعل ان تؤشر الى غلق
هذا الملف ملف الاسرى في اليمن غلقا
نهائيا وتصفير المعتقلات
بدايه اسعد الله مساءك اخي العزيز انت
وجميع الساده المشاهدين طبعا هذه هي
العمليه الثانيه بعد العمليه التي تمت في
في اكتوبر 2020 والتي شملت 1065
اسير ومختطف تم تبادلهم على الرغم من انه
في تلك الفتره كان الاتفاق على 1420 ثم
نتيجه تلاعبات معينه من قبل ميليشيات ادى
الى تقليص العدد الى 1065 الان نفس الشيء
كانت المفاوضات في في عمان في فبراير
ومارس الماضي من العام الماضي 2022 كان
الاتفاق على 223
اسير ومختطف يجب تبادلهم لكن حدث طبعا ان
توقفت عمليه برمتها منذ مارس 2022
لنعود بعد عمليه التقارب التي حدثت ما بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايران وربما
بضغوط من المملكه
عاده الميليشيات الى طاوله المفاوضات التي
تمت في الشهر الماضي في بيرن في سويسرا
وتم الاتفاق من من العدد الالفين 223
مدينه كان قد تم الاتفاق عليهم اصلا تم
الاتفاق على
887 شخصا وبالتالي
سيكون هناك لقاء قادم بعد عيد الفطر
المبارك
لبدء مناقشه
الاستمراريه العمليه لماذا ان كانت بالفعل
قد تم الاتفاق على هذا العدد 2223 لماذا
يتم تقليصه الى 800 اليوم وليس من الاجدا
ان يزيد ربما حتى عن العدد الذي كان متفقا
عليه خاصه بعد التفاهم السعودي
الايراني والمباحثات التي تجري وجرت كذلك
بالوسط العماني
دائما الميليشيات الحوثيات
تبدل جهود كبيره من اجل ان تجعل هذا الملف
ملف للضغط السياسي وهو ما نرفضه تماما
وبالتالي
نصر على ان هذا الملف ملف انساني ولا يمكن
ان يكون مصدر من مصادر
الملفات السياسيه او الضغوطات والابتزاز
السياسي ولهذا السبب تظل عمليه التبادل
تحرس الميليشيات على ان تظل ظل هذا الملف
مفتوحا
ويستمر هذه العمليه من التجزئه للاعداد مع
انه يعني يذكر الجميع ان الاتفاق على مبدا
الكل مقابل الكل كان في الكويت في 2016 في
بدايه الحرب ثم تم التاكيد عليه في لقاء
جنيف في 2017 ثم تاكيد التاكيد عليه في
ستوكهولم في ديسمبر 2018
كل هذه التاكيدات ورغم كل هذه الموافقات
من قبل ميليشيات الا اننا عندما نصل الى
مرحله التنفيذ او الخطوات التنفيذيه
وتبادل الاسماء تبدا وضع العراقيل
والتسويف
والمماطلات مما يؤدي الى تجزئه هذا الملف
بحيث حدث كما يعني في ايام مارتنج رفت
العمليه الوحيده بعد جهد الجهيده التي
كانت 1065 والان هذه العمليه
887 وكل ما نتمناه ان يكون هذا الحراك
السياسي الدولي والاقليمي هو فعلا ضاغط
على الميليشيات بحيث نصل الى تصفير
الزنازين وانهاء ملف الاسرى والمختطفين
سيدنا نبيل كانت الرابطه الانسانيه لحقوق
الانسان وتحالف نساء من اجل السلام في
اليمن تحدثت عن اختطاف اكثر من 1781 امراه
يمنيه خلال فتره من 2017 حتى
نتحرك حالات وارقام كثيره عن اختفاء
واعتقانات للنساء فهل للمراه اليمنيه او
الحضور في في هذا الملف ملف تبادل
السجناء والاسرى اليوم ام انه منسي في هذه
المفاوضات حقيقه
طبعا موضوع المراه نحن حريصين عليه جدا
وحاولنا بشكل كبير بتواصل مع الاسر حتى
يعطونا اسماء الفتيات التي تم اخذهن
واختطافهن خلال الفترات الماضيه حتى يتم
ادراجهم ضمن كشوفات العمليات المبادله
لدينا الان عدد من الاسماء ستكون موضوعه
ضمن العمليه القادمه التي نسعى اليها
العمليه القادمه خلال لانه هذه العمليه
الان ستستمر اربعه ايام هل هي ضمن هذه
المرحله من مراحل القادمه ومتى تحديدا لا
لا لا هذه المرحله ليست اربعه ايام هي
ثلاثه ايام فقط اليوم اول يوم فيها وفيها
عمليه انتقال طائرتين من عدن الى صلاته
ما فيها اي اسماء من نساء يمنيات معتقدات
لا لا لا لا يوجد فيها اسماء نساء والعدد
الذي سيتم التبادل ليس كما وضعتم في
الشريط الاخباري 249 فقط اليوم من الذين
سيتم الافراج عنهم من الميليشيات الحوثيه
بالاضافه الى 70 اساني مختطف تابعين
للحكومه الشرعيه سيتم الافراج عنهم في
عمليه التبادل بمعنى ان الطائرتين
المتجهتين من عدن الى صنعاء ستحمل كل
واحده فيهم رجال نبيل بالنسبه بالنسبه
للمراه اليمنيه او المعتقلات من النساء
اليمنيات هل لديكم خطه للعمل على يعني
ادراجهم ضمن هذه العمليه ومتى
عندنا مجموعه من السيدات اللاتي صدر بحقه
قرارات
تسميها الميليشيات احكاما بعضهن بالاعدام
بعضهن بالسجن سيكون ضمن من يتم وضعهم في
العمليه القادمه التي يفترض ان تتم عمليه
المفاوضات عليها ما بعد عيد الفطر المبارك
ايضا
سنحرص على ان نرصد اكبر عدد من الاسماء
لان الميليشيات للاسف الشديد تهدد الاهالي
بانهم اذا ما قدموا الاسماء اسماء فتياتهم
الينا
سيقومون باعطائهم تهم جنائيه او تهم
مختلفه بحيث يعني هذا يسبب نوع من الضغط
على الاهالي نحن حافظين على ملف المراه
سنعمل على ذلك بشكل كبير شكرا جزيلا لك
نبيل عبد الحفيظ وكيل وزاره الشؤون
القانونيه وحقوق الانسان يمنيه من القاهره
والى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث كشفت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه عن قيام القوات
الاوكرانيه بالانسحاب من بعض الاراضي في
مدينه باخ متماشيني روسيا هجوما جديدا
بالمدفعيه الثقيله على مدى اليومين الماضي
اضافه الدفاع البريطانيه في تحديثها
اليومي بان القوات الاوكرانيه تواجه مشاكل
كبيره تتعلق باعاده الامداد لكنها نفذت
انسحابات منظمه من مواقع اضطرت للتنازل
عنها
قد حتىت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه نالين
على مطالبه موسكو بوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا
لافيته الى عدم وجود اي دوله اخرى مؤثره
على روسيا كالصين
عن التزامها بحل ولكنني بصراحه اتساءل
لماذا الموقف الصيني حتى الان لا يتضمن
دعوه روسيا المعتديه الى وقف الحرب
30 عاما مرت على العلاقات السعوديه
الاوكرانيه رئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير في
وقت سابقا لديها علاقات جيده مع السعوديه
بعد حزمه المساعدات الانسانيه التي قدمت
لاوكرانيا بنحو 400 مليون دولار وخلال
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه قامت السعوديه
بجهود وساطه الافراج عن عشره اسره من خمس
دول فضلا عن الزيارتين التي اجراها وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
الى كيب وموسكو لتخفيف حده التوتر
من الرياضه السفير الاوكراني لدى السعوديه
اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه في
الرياض
الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي في لقاء تلفزيوني
سابق كان قال بان العلاقات بين اوكرانيا
والمملكه في افضل مستوياتها منذ 30 عاما
كما قال لماذا
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني لعلاقات بهذا الوصف
الان في هذا التوقيت
اليوم هو يوم خاص
فهو
يسجل فيه هذه هي الذكرى للعلاقات بين
اوكرانيا
والجميع
يحتفي بهذه العقود الثلاثه من الاحترام
المتبادل والتعاون الاقتصادي وبعض مشاريع
التنميه الانسانيه اوكرانيا تقدر امكانيات
السعوديه
واكبر الاقتصادات نمو وندرك
المحلي تحت ظل الرؤيه المحليه للمملكه
وهذه ايضا تنسجم مع اجنده اوكرانيا فنحن
نسعى لتنويع اقتصادا
للاستعداد
لعضوياتنا في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي الوقت
ذاته
النحسد للدفاع عن بلدنا ضد
غزو الروسي على مختلف الجبهات ونحن نفخر
بهذه الشراكه مع السعوديه التي تمكننا من
ان نصبح اكثر قوه
ساتحدث عن الموقف السعودي من الحرب
الاوكرانيه سيدنا ترينكو
في بدايه هذه الحرب وربما حتى وقت قريب
كانت هناك اتهامات من كثير من بعض الاطراف
او من كثير الاطراف الغربيه من وسائل
الاعلام بان
السعوديه تحتضن روسيا في هذه الحرب او
تنحاز بشكل كبير
لروسيا في هذه الحرب كيف كيف تصف الموقف
السعودي من هذه الحرب اليوم خاصه في ضوء
هذه الاتهامات التي انتشرت عن كثيره
اكد على ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه كانت
دائما
ثابته في موقفها ووفقا للقانون الدولي
وخاصه
بدعمها لاوكرانيا
وقرارات الجمعيه العموميه الامم المتحده
التي تطالب
بوقف الغزو الروسي واستعاده السياده
الاوكرانيه على اراضيها هذه هذا هو الاساس
للعلاقات السياسيه وكانت السعوديه قد قامت
بقراري المهمين في تقدير المساعده
الانسانيه لمساعده المدنيين الاوكرانيين
الذين تاثروا بهذه الحرب اضافه لذلك اريد
ان اؤكد على ان السعوديه واوكرانيا على
الرغم من الوضع الامني المتازم
تمكنوا من المحافظه على العلاقه
الاقتصاديه
وضمان الاستفاده المتبادله لايجاد فرص
العمل
والتحقيق الربح الذي يحتاجه تحتاجه شعوبنا
اريد ان اقف معك واستغل وجودك معي ايضا
الحديث عن الموقف اليوم في الحرب
الاوكرانيه يعني كثير من من الوساطات
الدوليه قدمت وعرضت ايضا بين الاطراف
المتصارعه لكن لم تنجح حتى الان
لماذا
برايك السيده نتولي لم تنجح كل هذه
الوسطاطات في وقف هذه الحرب او نزيفها حتى
ثابته واعزمه عن ان تبقى في الدفاع عن
اراضيها ونحن ايضا لدينا هذا الاصرار
لاستعاده اراضينا واستعاده السياده لذلك
لدينا حشد لموارد دوليه ومعليه
وتمكنا في 22 العام الماضي في استعاده عدد
كبير من اراضينا التي استولت عليها روسيا
واعادتها تحت السيطره الاوكرانيه سنتمكن
من النجاح بعشرين 23
بمواصله النشاطات السياسيه والعسكريه او
الدبلوماسيه او العسكريه
لمساعده الشعب واستعاده السياده
ضمن
الحدود المعترف بها دوليه على الصعيد
الدبلوماسي نواصل جهودنا في
تقويه نظام الع قوبات على روسيا
ومحاسبه من قاموا بارتكاب جرائم حرب على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه السعوديه كانت دائما
الى جانبنا في هذه الوساطه للتوسط لاطلاق
صراحه اسرى الحرب
نقدر هذه المشاركه من السعوديه ونواصل هذه
العلاقه
للنجاح في هذه العلاقات الدبلوماسيه التي
تمكن اوكرانيا من استعاده الازدهار
والاستقرار لشعبها سيد بترن اليوم عن هجوم
الربيع المقبل يعني
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الكثير من
التقارير تتحدث عن هذا الهجوم وتطرح
سيناريوهات ايضا للتعامل مع الموقف الان
على الارض هل تعتقدون في اوكرانيا بانها
ستكون بدايه لنهايه هذه الحرب ام بدايه
لحرب طويله ايضا والى اي مدى اوكرانيا
قادره على تحمل كل فتره هكذا وضع سريع
بالحديس عن الموقف الاساسي لاوكرانيا اود
ان اؤكد انه على كل الصعد اوكرانيا كل ما
تريده هو السلام وهذا في
الصيغه صيغه السلام التي طرحها
وقد دعونا المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
الانضمام لنا في تنفيذ هذه الخطه واقترحنا
ان تكون المملكه احد الاطراف الرياديه في
احد عناصر الخطه وهي اطلاق سراح الاسرى
الذي يساعدنا في اعاده المرحلين الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذه الصيغه صيغه
السلام الشامله
وسنواصل تنفيذ هذه الخطه في انحاء العالم
وترويجها في العالم
بتنفيدها نتمكن من تحقيق السلامه الدائم
في اوكرانيا ونتمكن من استعاده الاستقرار
الى المنطقه
بشكل موسع
وافريقيا حتى وشرق الاوسط واوروبا وهذا
يعيد السلام للارض الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا
لك سفير
رابعه مستمره ايضا فيها بعد قليل سلسله من
الحرمين تستعرض قصه انشاء 250
تغطي ساحات المظله تغطي ساحات المسجد
النبوي
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان اطلاق اربع مناطق
اقتصاديه خاصه في كل من الرياض جازان راس
الخير ومدينه الملك عبد الله الاقتصاديه
في رابط ولي العهد السعوديه كدام المناطق
الاقتصاديه الخاصه ستفتح افاقا جديده
للتنميه معتمده على المزايا التنافسيه لكل
منطقه لدعم القطاعات الحيويه والواعده
ومنها اللوجستيه والصناعيه والتقنيه
وغيرها
[موسيقى]
23 يوما تنقضي من شهر رمضان شهد خلالها
المسجد الحرام توافد اكثر من 22 مليون
معتمر ومصلن ويشهد المسجد الحرام في العشر
الاواخر من الشهر الفضيل كثافه كبيره من
المعتمرين والبصلين وسط خطط تنظيميه
وامنيه عاليه تقودها قوات امن العمره
بمشاركه عده جهات حكوميه
ايضا من الحرم المكي الشريف ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز اهلا نواف
في الاعداد كبيره اذا هذا اليوم كم وصلت
تقريبا ما هي ماذا عن خطط التنظيميه ايضا
لحركه المعتمرين والزهور
نعم خالد على الرغم من الكثافه العاليه في
اعداد المعتمرين والمصلين في المسجد
الحرام وساحاته الا ان هناك انسيابيه
عاليه في حركه المعتمرين والمصلين ضمن
الخطط التي وضعتها قوات امن العمره والتي
تركز على توزيع الكثافات والتواجد في
المسجد الحرام على المداخل وايضا على
المداخل الخارجيه اضافه الى التعامل
اللحظي مع اي اعاقه في حركه المعتمرين او
المصلين من خلال مركز القياده هو السيطره
الذي يرصد بشكل لحظي اي بلاغ ويوجه الفرق
الميدانيه له لمعالجه اي مشاكل نحن نلاحظ
خلال الايام الماضيه انسيابيه عاليه على
الرغم من الاعداد الكبيره حتى يوم امس
تجاوز عدد المعتمرين والمصلين في المسجد
الحرام اكثر
22 مليون مصلي ومعتمر يوم امس تحديدا عدد
المعتمرين والمصلين في نفس اليوم يقارب
المليون و500 الف مصلي ومعتمر اعداد
الزوار
والمعتمرين يتزايد بشكل كبير في العشر
الاواخر من شهر رمضان اتواجد الان امام
باب الملك عبد العزيز كما تشاهدون وهو
واحد من الابواب الرئيسيه
المخصصه لدخول المعتمرين هو واحد من ثلاث
ابواب بالاضافه الى باب السلام و باب
الملك فهد هنا رئاسه شؤون الحرمين والمسجد
الحرام خصص 158 باب من اصل
20010 ابواب لاستقبال المعتمرين والمصلين
اليوم ايضا رفعت الجهود
لاستقبال المصلين لصلاه الجمعه
تم التواجد المكثف على المداخل الرئيسيه
والابواب وتقديم الارشاد والدعم للمعتمرين
والمصلين كما نشاهد الان نلاحظ هذه
الانسيابيه في حركه
المعتمرين من هذا الباب من هذا الباب
ونشاهد ايضا
رجال قوات امن العمره وهم يتواجدون في
الاعلى ويقدمون التعليمات والتوجيهات
للمعتمرين والمصلين لضمان استمرار
انسيابيه الحركه ويتم هذا بشكل مستمر وفقا
لاوقات الصلوات واوقات الذروه توضع حواجز
حديديه لتغيير المسارات وتوزيع الكثافات
وغيرها اضافه الى وجود عده خدمات تقدم
للمعتمرين مثل خدمه استخراج الاساور
الكترونيا للاطفال وكبار السن خلال دقيقه
واحده تستخرج في حال فقدان الطفل او كبير
السن يتوجه الى رجال الامن او المرشدين
للاتصال
بوالدي والده او المسؤول عنه
لارشاده الى الموقع الذي يجب ان يتجه اليه
انسيابيه عاليه لازلنا مستمرين
متبقي ثمانيه ايام على نهايه شهر رمضان
هنا ايضا الاعتكاف المسجد الحرام يستقبل
المعتكفين جهود متعدده
والجهود الامنيه ربما تشكل هنا الفارق
الكبير في استقبال المعتمرين والمصلين في
المسجد الحرام شكرا لكل العربيه من الحرم
المكي الشريف
نذهب الى المدينه المنوره حيث تغطي
المظلات المتحركه في المسجد النبوي الشريف
مساحه
140,000 متر وتصل اوزانها الى 10000 طن
تقل المصلين والزوار اشعه الشمس وهطول
الامطار سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
مظلات المسجد النبوي التي يستظل تحت ظلها
230 الف مصل تقيهم من اشعه الشمس وهطول
الامطار وتتشكل ابعاد المظله الواحده منها
نحو 25 مترا مربع ووزنها نحو اربعين طن
داخل مسجد النبوي توجد 12 مظله منقسمه الى
حصتين في ساحات المسجد النبوي 250 مظله
المظلات هذه بارتفاعات متفاوته وحده تعلن
اخرى الارتفاع المنخفض منها 14 متر و40 سم
والاخرى ب 15 متر و30 سم
جميعها اثناء الاغلاق يكون ارتفاعها 21
متر و70 سم
[موسيقى]
مئه واربعين الف متر مربع هي المساحه
الاجماليه التي تغطيها مظلات ساحات المسجد
النبوي التي تعمل بنظام الي لفتحها وغلقها
تتم التحكم فيها عن طريق غرف تحكم رئيسيه
في بدروم المسجد النبوي او مواقف المسجد
النبوي يتم فتحها قبل الشروق الشمس ب15
دقيقه ويتم اغلاقها قبل غروب الشمس ب 45
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
يعد الشكل الهندسي للمظلات فريد الشكل
والتصميم ويشكل التاج والرمح في نهايه
المظله من الاعلى المصنوعان من النحاس
الملمع والمطلب الذهبي بريقا خلابا يلفت
انظار المصلين
والزوار من المسجد النبوي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
رابع ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل شدات
واسعه بمسلسل سفر برلك توثيقه قصه تاجير
اهالي المدينه على يد العثمانيين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدار واسعه صاحبه
المسلسل التاريخي سفر برلك الذي يحكي قصه
التهجير واباده اهالي المدينه المنوره عام
1914 على يد الدوله العثمانيه نجوم عرب
وسعوديون
وسعوديون نعم شاركوا في المسلسل الذي حقق
مشاهدات عاليه خلال شهر رمضان بعض ملامح
المسلسل في هذا التقرير
[تصفيق]
الوجه الاخر للدوله العثمانيه في بلاد
العرب عنوان عريض لمسلسل سفر برلك الذي
وثق ويلات واحداثا تاريخيه عاشتها المدينه
المنوره على ايدي العثمانيين قبل اكثر من
قرن
[موسيقى]
المدينه الهادئه والوادعه لم تكن كذلك في
عام
1914 حيث قضى اهلها بين تهجير واباده
وثقها المسلسل وفق عمليه انتاج عربيه ضخمه
ارشادات واسعه لقاها مسلسل سفر برلك بين
المشاهدين العرب والسعوديين خصوصا لتوثيقه
حقبه دمويه تاريخيه غابت عنها عمليه
الانتاج الدرامي طوال العقود
لوحات شعريه غنائيه وظفت في العديد من
مشاهد المسلسل الذي حل ضمن اعلى الاعمال
الرمضانيه مشاهده عبر تطبيق شاهد
[موسيقى]
لو
هليت وين الهلاهل والعرس رفع ذائقه
المشاهد العربي
وتطلعاته لاعمال تاريخيه توثق الاحداث
بدون قيود
الممثل السعودي الدكتور مؤيد الثقفي مؤيد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابع مبروك عليكم
نجاح المسلسل وكل الاصدار
الرائعه اللي شفناها
ومبروك عليك انت نجاحك في الدور العظيم
اللي قمت فيه يعني في ثنائي حلقاته كلمني
عن المسلسل هذا بالنسبه لمؤيد الثقفي يعني
حياك الله استاذ خالد شاكر لك الاستضافه
وانت استاذنا ونعلمنا يعطيك العافيه اول
شيء المسلسل هذا للامانه هو ليس بالنسبه
لمؤيد ليس مجرد مسلسل انا اول ما عرض علي
اني اقوم بتجربه اداء لاترشح لهذا العمل
وكان في ذاك الوقت العمل تحت او بقياده
المخرج الراحل السوري رحمه الله عليه
الاستاذ حاتم علي كان كل فخر وشرف طبعا
اول ما قرات النص
صراحه صدمت بهذه الحقبه التاريخيه اللي
انا انا كنت ما اعرف عنها كثير صدمت
بالتفاصيل اللي قراتها رجعت تبحث فيه في
مصادر تاريخيه كثير قعدت اقرا كثير
للامانه
صاعقه كبيره كانت لي كممثل وبالعكس اضاف
لهذا العمل قيمه لكل فنان في هذه الحياه
يعني له اعمال يجد قيمه فيها ويجد رساله
وجوديه لنفسه فيها فانا وجدت انه في قيمه
عاليه من خلال هذا العمل خلال الفن من
خلال التمثيل اقدر
بتثبيت وقائع تاريخيه حقيقيه صارت
ومع المفارقات فين كنا وفين صرنا اليوم
ولله الحمد والمنه اللهم لك الحمد على
نعمه الامن والامان طبعا هو عمل ملحمه
ملحمه تاريخي اتشرف اني كنت احد افراده
وبالنسبه لي هو عمل وطني يعني هو كان
العمل الاخير اللي كان من المفروض ان
يخرجوا حاتم علي الراحل رحمه الله ثم بعد
ذلك جاء مساعده اللي هو اعتقد هو اللي
استلم اخراج هذا الفيلم او عفوا المسلسل
المسلسل تحس انه متعوب عليه انتاجيا ومكلف
يعني مو مقصرين
المنتجين في في دعمو بشكل كبير لكن
دورك انت كيف تصف مؤيد يعني خاصه انه انا
اشوف كثير من الاصدقاء والتهاني وكثير من
يعني الاجلال لك على ما قدمت فيها المسلسل
شخصيه شخصيه عبد الرحمن صح
الشكر لك استاذ خالد على هذا الكلام
صراحه يعني الله يعطيك العافيه وشكرا
لجميع الناس اللي صراحه يعني قدرونه
وشاركونا بتعليقاتهم ومشاعرهم النبيله
والجميله في هذا العمل والله للامانه يعني
فعلا من اكثر الادوار واقربها الى قلبي هو
الدور رضوان في هذا العمل لانه رضوان كان
شخصيه بكل بساطه هي شخص عمره 18 19 سنه
رضوان
رضوان وفي عمر خمسه سنين شاف عمه يقتل على
يد العثمانيين بكل ظلم وبكل حقد وبكل جور
وبكل ما تعنيه الكلمه من مهانه فنشا على
هذه التروما او نشا على هذه الصدمه فكان
طول الوقت ما بين في صراع ما بين ما بين
خوفو على اهله وخوفه على الوضع نفس الوقت
الطفل الصغير هذاك ما هو راضي على الظلم
اللي صاير فالحمد لله اتمنى اني اكون وفقت
في تجسيد هذه الشخصيه والفضل لله ثم يعود
طبعا القائمين على هذا العمل المخرج
الاستاذ الليث حجه للاداره الكفه وصراحه
وخير الملف يعني صراحه للاستاذ حاتم يعطيه
العافيه كان توجيهاته مستمره معانا في
اللوكيشن فالممثل حتى وانبرز فما هو بمجرد
ممثل ففريق العمل كله يعني يساعده في هذا
الشيء الحكايه نفسها حكايه هذا المسلسل
انا اعرف انه كمان تغير اسم المسلسل كان
اسم ثم تغير الى اسم سفر برلك لكن انت هل
في عوامل ساعدتك انه انت تنجح في تجسيد
الشخصيه بشكل
بهذا الشكل اللي شفناها يعني قراءات جديده
نصائح من من اشخاص معينين
والله طبعا
بلا شك المخرج يعني له الدور الكبير كان
معانا الاستاذ عروه العربي ايضا احد
مدربين تمثيل معانا في هذا العمل يعطيه
العافيه كل الشكر لهم لكن للامانه للامانه
القضيه الجوهريه استاذ خالد كان العمل ما
هو مجرد عمل بالنسبه لي مو بس لي انا ليو
لجميع زملائي الممثلين السعوديين اللي كنا
لانه نحن كنا نصور طبعا زي ما يقولوا
بايلوكيشن او خلال المواقع فكنا نحن
المدينه المنوره ممثلين المدينه المنوره
على على صله قريبه من بعض من الاستاذ محمد
وغيرنا فكان العمل بالنسبه لنا هو ما هو
مجرد عمل ولا لا هو قضيه وجوديه بالنسبه
لنا كسعوديين نحن لا يعني فعلا العم محمد
ابن المدينه المنوره فكان دائما طول ما
احنا في اللوكيشن وطول ما احنا في موقع
التصوير نسمع دائما بيتكلم على هذه الحدث
ويتكلم على تفاصيل فيها فكنا نتغذى كثيرا
يعني المساله مساله حقبه تبى تبينها انت
كممثل وهذه فرصتك وفرصه عمر بالنسبه لك
انك تظهرها بالطريقه الصحيحه بكل تفاصيلها
بتلك المشاعر حتى تتجلى الحقائق للناس
مبروك عليكم نجاح المسلسل يعطيكم العافيه
وموفقين والله انا سعيد استاذ خالد اني
استضفتك وهذا شرف كبير لي شكرا لي يا
حبيبي شكرا جزيلا لك
ممثل السعودي المعروف واحد نجوم مسلسل سفر
تشهد مدينه جده اليوم اجتماعا تشاوريه
لوزراء خارجيه دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
اضافه الى مصر والاردن والعراق ونقلت
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط عن مصدر الدبلوماسيه
العربيه القوله ان هذا الاجتماع التشاوري
قد يحسم الموقف من عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه وحضورها القمه المقرر عقدها في
الرياض في مايو المقبل وكان وزير الخارجات
المصري سامح شكري اول الواصلين قبل بدء
الاجتماع في جده
نذهب معكم الى متابعه هذه الصور من
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس وهي صوره صور
مباشره
للمحتاجين ايضا بعد اشهر من احتجاجات
عنيفه كذلك من المنتظر بالنسبه للفرنسية
القرار الذي ستصدره الهيئه القضائيه
العليا بشان اصلاح نظام التقاعد امام
المجلس حسب اخر الانباء ثلاثه خيارات اما
المصادقه على هذا الاصلاح او رفضه بالكامل
او جزئيا
والصلاح يتطلب رفع سر التقاعد القانون من
62 الى 64 عاما
ويتوقع بعض مؤيدي الاصلاح تعليق بعض مواده
بحسب السلطه التنفيذيه فان رفض المشروع
جاء بسبب الحاجه لمعالجه التدهور المالي
لصناديق التقاعد وشيخوخه السكان كان هذا
سببا في نشاه عدد من المظاهرات
والاحتجاجات وتخللتها
ايضا الاعمال عنف خلال الايام الماضيه
شهدت الكعبه المشرفه عددا من عمليات الهدم
والبناء على مدار تاريخها الطويل وتم
الترميمها حوالي 40 مره منذ بدايه العد
الاسلامي وكان لملوك السعوديه نصيب منها
شهدت الكعبه عددا من عمليات الترميم على
مدار حكم الدوله السعوديه حيث كان اول
ترميم لها في التاريخ الحديث على يد الملك
سعود بعد امره برفع السقف الخارجي للكعبه
وتجديد عمارته بالاضافه الى تجديد السقف
الداخلي لقدم الاخشاب وتاكلها كما تم
اصلاح الرخام الذي يكسو جدران الكعبه من
الداخل اما الترميم الثاني فكان في عهد
الملك خالد حيث تم ترميم مدخل الكعبه
وبابها الذي تغير بالكامل بعد ملاحظه خدوش
بارزه عليه فامر الملك في حينها بصنع باب
من الذهب الخالص وفي مايو من عام
1996 امر الملك فهد بن عبد العزيز باعاده
ترميم الكعبه بشكل كامل وكانت الكعبه خلال
فتره الترميم محاطه بحاجز خشبي حيث يجري
العمل على ترميمها دون ان يتضرر الطائفون
اما عن اخر ترميم للكعبه المشرفه فكان في
العهد الحالي على يد الملك سلمان الذي امر
بتجديد رخام الشاذروان المحيط بالكعبه مع
المحافظه على الاحجار المرمريه الثمانيه
بالاضافه الى تبليط سطح الكعبه بالرخام
وصيانه بابها محمد السيف العربيه
الختام بالعربي هذه الاولى خطوات السلام
تلحقه ان شاء الله
تفاهمات اكبر
وزير الداخليه اليمنيه يكشف عن تفاهمات
سلام قادمه ويؤكدها ان دعم السعوديه
والتحالف وراء التحرير الاسرى
الدفاع البريطانيه تكشف عن انسحاب من
باخمه وسط خسف روسيا بالمدفعيه الثقيله
الامير محمد بن سلمان يطلق اربعه مناطق
اقتصاديه خاصه السعوديه قبله الصناعات
لوجستيه والتقنيه
واكثر من 22 مليون معتمر وزائر للمسجد
الحرام خلال شهر رمضان حتى الان وسط خدمات
متكامله
واسعه بمسلسل سفر
توثيق لقصه تهجير اهالي المدينه على يد
العثماني
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات